ALL RIGHT, AWESOME SHOW.
WE'LL PICK IT UP OR YOU LEFT
OFF.
I AM LEARNING FROM HER THIS IS
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" FROM
WASHINGTON.
THE SENATE PSYCH OUT.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
>> NOW IT LOOKS LIKE AS A
REPUBLICAN SCALE BACK THE U.S.
SENATE RACES IN PLAY.
>> EXTENDED CANDIDATES MIGHT
RUIN THE REPUBLICAN CHANCES FOR
RETAKING THE CHAMBER.
>> IS A TIME TO BELIEVE THE
DEMOCRATS CAN KEEP THE HOUSE?
>> Laura: RIGHT OFF THE BAT,
LET ME BE VERY CLEAR.
MOST OF WHAT YOU ARE HEARING
ABOUT THE REPUBLICANS' SO-CALLED
DIRE POSITION IN THE MIDTERM
SENATE RACES, IT'S DESIGNED TO
DO ONE THING.
DEMORALIZE THE CONSERVATIVE BASE
AND DEPRESS TURNOUT.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THESE
CANDIDATES, LET'S FOCUS ON THE
SENATE, DESERVES TO WIN BACK
OVER THEIR LIBERAL OPPONENTS.
IT'S NOT EVEN CLOSE.
NOW WAS NOT THE TIME FOR
SECOND-GUESSING OR "SEE, I TOLD
YOU SO.
"YOU KNOW I SUPPORTED DAVE
McCORMICK IN PENNSYLVANIA OVER
MET MATT OZ.
I DID IT NIGHT AFTER NIGHT.
BUT OZ WON.
HE IS THE NOMINEE AND HE'S
WORKING HIS TAIL OFF TRAVELING
THE STATE MEETING WITH EVERY
VOTER HE CAN TRY TO WIN OVER AS
MANY AS POSSIBLE.
JOHN FETTERMAN, HE IS A YOUNGER,
BOLDER JOE BIDEN BUT IN GYM RANK
CLOTHING.
HE'S A -- SHE'S IN A HOODIE
USING CLEVER CONSULTANTS.
HE CAN'T ACTUALLY ARGUE,  , THAT
THE DEMOCRAT SENATE IS SOMEHOW
GOOD FOR PENNSYLVANIA.
THAT IS A JOKE.
FOR WHAT THEY HAVE DONE ON THE
FRACKING ISSUE ALONE THESE
PEOPLE NEED TO BE THROWN OUT ON
THEIR BUTTS.
THE PRESS, THEY WANT REPUBLICANS
TO BELIEVE ALL HOPE IS LOST WITH
HIS TRUMPET ENDORSED CANDIDATES.
I GET IT, IN AN IDEAL WORLD,
TOTALLY OBJECTIVE PRESS CORPS,
THEY WOULD BE DOING BETTER.
FEAR.
YOU FIGHT WITH THE ARMY YOU
HAVE, NOT THE ARMY YOU WISH YOU
HAD.
HERE'S WHERE OUR POLITICAL
SOLDIERS ARE.
THIS IS ACCORDING TO THE WEBSITE
FIVETHIRTYEIGHT.
IN OHIO, IT'S A STATISTICAL TIE
BETWEEN AMERICAN FIRST
CONSERVATIVE J.D. VANCE AND
PHONY POPULIST TIM RYAN.
IN GEORGIA, FAVORITES ON
HERSCHEL WALKER IS LESS THAN TWO
POINTS DOWN ON UBER LIBERAL
RAPHAEL WARNOCK.
IN ALABAMA.
MARK KELLY, A RUBBER STAMP FOR
CHUCK SCHUMER ON EVERYTHING
LEADS BLAKE MASTERS.
YOUNG GUY, NEVER RAN BEFORE.
IN THE MOST EXPENSIVE RACE IN
AMERICA IN PENNSYLVANIA WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO GIVE UP ALL HOPE
BECAUSE THEY SAY UNCLE FESTER IS
BEATING DR. OZ.
OKAY.
LET ME REMIND EVERYONE IT'S ONLY
THE END OF AUGUST.
MOST PEOPLE AREN'T EVEN
FOLLOWING THESE RACES YET.
BUT THEY ARE FOLLOWING THEIR
FAMILY BUDGET.
THEY KNOW WE ARE ALREADY IN
RECESSION.
60% OF THOSE POLLED BY NBC.
DEMOCRATS ARE SO BAD FOR AMERICA
THAT 58% BELIEVE THAT OUR BEST
DAYS ARE BEHIND US.
IF PESSIMISM WERE OF GROWTH
STOCK, THE DEMOCRATS WOULD
BELONG IN IT.
AMERICANS ARE GETTING POORER AND
WEAKER WITH LIBERALS RUNNING THE
SHOW.
THE MEDIA KNOWS THIS.
THE DEMOCRATS KNOW THIS.
THE CANDIDATES RUNNING ON THE
FANTASY OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
ABORTION, THEY KNOW IT AND THEY
DON'T CARE.
74% OF AMERICANS ARE NOW SAYING
THE COUNTRY IS GOING IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION.
STAGGERING FIGURE.
I GET THE LEFT WANTS A NARRATIVE
ABOUT THE REPUBLICANS BEING ON
THE ROPES, IT'S ALL WISHFUL
THINKING.
I'M TELLING YOU THIS.
THERE'S OTHER POLLING OUT THERE
THAT YOU MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER
AS WELL.
TRAFALGAR, FAIRLY ACCURATE
OUTFIT, THEY HAVE J.D. VANCE UP
BY 5 IN OHIO.
ANOTHER CANDIDATE UP BY 3.
BECAUSE DOWN 4 IN PENNSYLVANIA.
NOTICE HOW DEMOCRATS, ALL OF
THIS IS SWIRLING AROUND, NOTICE
HOW THEY NEVER EVER ATTACK EACH
OTHER.
PELOSI EVEN GOT THE SQUAD TO
QUIET DOWN.
THAT WAS SOME PIECE.
LEAVE IT TO THE G.O.P.
ESTABLISHMENT TO SHOOT INSIDE
THE TENT JUST IN TIME FOR THE
MIDTERMS.
>> PROBABLY A GREATER LIKELIHOOD
TO HAVE SPLITS IN THE SENATE.
SENATE RACES ARE JUST DIFFERENT.
THEY ARE STATEWIDE.
CANDIDATE QUALITY HAS A LOT TO
DO WITH THE OUTCOME.
>> Laura: McCONNELL'S WAY I
GUESS OF SAYING "SEE, I TOLD YOU
SO."
JUST AS THE MEDIA'S FOOD WITH
LIZ CHENEY WHEN SHE WAS RABBIT
ON TRUMP, THEY SWOON OVER
McCONNELL WHEN HE THROWS COLD W.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE I AM SAYING
THIS BUT MITCH McCONNELL IS
RIGHT.
>> MITCH McCONNELL IS RIGHT.
>> I AGREE WITH
MITCH McCONNELL.
CAN'T BELIEVE I'M SAYING THIS.
THE QUALITY OF CANDIDATE REALLY
MUCH MORE.
>> Laura: NO, WE DO NOT NEED
THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
PLAYING THE ROLE OF A POLITICAL
PUNDIT.
WE HAVE PLENTY OF THOSE.
LOOK, IT'S NO SECRET McCONNELL
PREFERS OLD-STYLE REPUBLICANS TO
THE NEWISH POPULIST OF THE
JOSH HAWLEY, TED CRUZ VARIETY
FOR THE NEW G.O.P. EZEKIEL TO
THE OLD GUARD AND THEY FELT THAY
LONG BEFORE TRUMP.
THE RISE OF THE D PARTY IN 2009
WHEN I WAS BACK ON THE RADIO, T.
THEY WERE A BUNCH OF XENOPHOBES,
CONSPIRACY THEORIST,
ISOLATIONIST.
AFTER TRUMP, HE SHOWED UP, THEY
ADDED CULTIST TO THAT LIST.
THE TRUTH IS THE REAL OUTLIERS
IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY ARE THE
BUSH REPUBLICANS.
THEY HAVE BEEN OUT OF STEP WITH
THEIR OWN VOTERS FOR YEARS.
REALLY IF YOU WANT TO BE PRECISE
ABOUT IT, PRETTY MUCH BACK TO
THE 2006 MIDTERMS WE KNEW ALL WE
HAD TO KNOW BACK THEN.
AND THEN BACK IN 2016, THE
REPUBLICAN RULING CLASS, THEY
WANTED JIM TO BE PRESIDENT BUT
NO OFFENSE, THE G.O.P. BASE
WANTED THE FIRE TO STAND UP TO
THEM, THEY STILL WANT THAT.
THEY GET PARTY LEADERSHIP THE
TWO OFTEN TREATS THEM, THEY FEEL
LIKE SECOND-CLASS CITIZENS.
AND THEN WHEN TRUMP WHILE
EVERYONE, WHEN HE BECAME
PRESIDENT, RATTLING THE OLD
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HOLD ON THE
PARTY, THE OLD GUARD, THEY
WEREN'T HAPPY.
THEY TOLERATED TRUMP BUT THEY
NEVER REALLY RESPECTED THEM.
BEYOND THE TONE AND THE STYLE OF
TRUMP, THEY RECALLED THAT HIS
POSITIONS ON CHINA TRADE,
IMMIGRATION, AND THE LONG WARS
WE HAVE BEEN FIGHTING.
OF COURSE THE POSTELECTION
FRENZY, JANUARY 6, ALL THAT,
THAT DIDN'T JUST GIVE DEMOCRATS
A STORY LINE OF DEMOCRACY UNDER
ATTACK.
IT GAVE THE G.O.P. ESTABLISHMENT
AND OUT AS WELL.
SENATOR McCONNELL THESE ARE
THE CANDIDATES WE HAVE.
THE LEFT IS DENNIS ENDING UP ON
THEM WITH VICIOUS AD CAMPAIGNS
AND HUGE WAR CHEST.
THANKFULLY McCONNELL SUPER PAC
IS SPENDING IN KEY RACES, THAT'S
GOOD.
THE GOVERNMENT HOW MUCH MORE
COULD BE RAISED IF REPUBLICANS
AND EVEN INDEPENDENCE THOUGHT IT
WAS ALL FOR ONE, ONE FOR ALL.
McCONNELL MAY BE, JUST MAYBE
SEEMS TO BE GETTING THE MESSAGE.
HERE HE WAS TODAY.
>> LOOKING AT THE SENATE, THE
CHANCES.
WE'VE A 50/50 SENATE RIGHT NOW.
50/50 NATION.
I THINK THE OUTCOME IS LIKELY TO
BE VERY, VERY CLOSE EITHER WAY.
THE STAKES WILL BE BIG BECAUSE
IF BOTH THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE
FLIP, I THINK THE PRESIDENT WILL
BE A MODERATE.
HE WON'T HAVE ANY CHOICE.
>> Laura: OKAY.
AGAIN, WE NEED LESS OF A PUNDIT
AND MORE OF A LEADER.
RALLY THE TROOPS.
WE DON'T NEED THE NUMBER COUNT
FOR McCONNELL.
WE NEED THE TROOPS RAILING FOR
AMERICA.
ENTIRELY RATIONAL FOR G.O.P.
VOTERS WHO WANT TO CHANGE THE
SENATE, NOT HOSTING EMPOWER THE
OLD G.O.P. ESTABLISHMENT BUT IN
THE PRIMARY RACES TO CHOOSE
CANDIDATES WHO THEY BELIEVE
WILL ACTUALLY DO THE RIGHT THING
IF THEY ARE ELECTED.
INSTEAD OF COMPLAINING ABOUT OUR
CANDIDATES, KIND OF BEING
WISHY-WASHY, WE SHOULD RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS GROUP IS ACTUALLY
GREAT.
OUR NOMINEES WITH A FEW
EXCEPTIONS LIKE COLORADO ARE
POLITICAL NEWCOMERS.
THEY HAVEN'T HAD A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE.
BUT THAT'S OKAY.
THEY ARE OUT THERE FIGHTING FOR
THE AVERAGE PERSON.
THEY SHOULD BE RESPECTED FOR
GETTING THE RING.
THIS IS A GREAT MAKEUP TO THE
CHANGE OF THE SENATE AND WE
SHOULD BE EXCITED ABOUT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SWITCH THINGS UP
IN THE G.O.P.
OF COURSE WE COULD HAVE
NOMINATED A BUNCH OF ROMNEY
CLONES AND THEN THE PRESS WOULD
BE HAPPIER WITH US.
BUT THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN BAD FOR
THE COUNTRY.
THE WHOLE POINT OF THIS MOVEMENT
IS THAT WE NEED A PARTY THAT
LOOKS OUT FOR A REGULAR
HARDWORKING AMERICANS.
YES, BLUE-COLLAR AMERICANS.
IT DOESN'T JUST GO ALONG WITH
WHAT EVER THE MEDIA AND THE
GLOBALISTS WANT.
WE HAVE TRIED THAT.
IT DOESN'T WORK.
NOW IS NOT THE TIME FOR SCORE
SETTLING.
CERTAINLY NOT THE TYPE OF
BACKBITING.
I DON'T WANT TO DO IT.
NOW IS THE TIME TO WIN, TAKE
BACK THE SENATE, STOP THE BIDEN
WRECKING BALL FROM DESTROYING
WHAT'S LEFT OF AMERICA.
IF OUR G.O.P. LEADERSHIP REALLY
CARES ABOUT THE FUTURE OF THIS
COUNTRY IS MUCH AS THEY SAY THEY
DO, THEY'LL DO EVERYTHING IN
THEIR POWER TO ELECT EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THIS G.O.P.
CANDIDATES.
THAT'S THE ANGLE.
AND NOW TONIGHT BREAKING NEWS,
HOURS AGO PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
LEGAL TEAM REQUESTED THE
APPOINTMENT OF A SPECIAL MASTER
TO ACT AS A THIRD PARTY IN
SCREENING THOSE SEIZED MATERIALS
FROM MAR-A-LAGO FOR POTENTIALLY
PRIVILEGED OR CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
IN THEIR REQUEST, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS NOTE THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AS A SHIELD THAT
PROTECTS AMERICANS.
IT CANNOT BE USED AS A WEAPON
FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES.
MY VIEW HERE IS THAT TRUMP HAS
BEEN MOST SUCCESSFUL WHEN HE IS
ON THE OFFENSIVE.
AND THE GOOD NEWS TO SEE T